qui sont ces cinq membres des hells
angels qui font toujours face à la
justice de quoi senti l'accusé alors les
cinq sont accusés de meurtre et de
complot pour meurtre alors en tête on à
claude berger c'est le membre fondateur
en fait du chapitre des hells angels de
sherbrooke
c'est l'ancien trompettiste en fait du
lancaster phonique de québec un ancien
professeur de musique oui il est en
liberté il se défend lui-même est
aujourd'hui bien de se défendre d'une
accusation de neuf meurtres prémédités
ensuite son collègue yvon tanguay c'est
aussi un des membres fondateurs du
chapitre de sherbrooke est également les
deux frères les deux frères vachon
françois et sylvain et pour terminer la
marche il ya à michel vallière alors les
accusations de meurtre prémédité
ces 9 7 5 7 et 9 bon alors on voyait
dans le reportage le procès chirac n'a
pas éradiqué les avengers congrès sont
toujours très présents et pas seulement
au québec qu'ils ont des activités aussi
ailleurs au canada
ils sont vraiment répartis un peu
partout en fait ils ont trente et un
chapitre au canada 380 membres à peu
près majoritairement ils sont situés en
ontario avec treize chapitres 150
membres une centaine de membres
également colombie britannique il ya
cinq chapitres du côté de l'alberta
quelques-uns également une petite
poignée en saskatchewan et au manitoba
et puis au québec ben écoute et il y
avait cinq chapitres il reste seulement
un qui est encore ouvert ils ont réussi
à le maintenir ouvert de peine et de
misère parce qu'il faut qu'ils aient au
moins six membres en règle qui ne sont
pas sous l'effet de conditions
judiciaires alors imaginez vous c'est un
peu compliqué d'en trouver pour se
reconstituer
pour l'instant il aura encore un bassin
de 60 70 membres qui peuvent régner sur
le march le marché du québec donc et ils
ont évidemment d'autres clubs écoles
pour les aider là on voit qu'ils ont
aussi de la concurrence du canada ils
sont pas tous à se partager les sources
tout seul bon évidemment il ya des
bacchus qui sont dans les maritimes ont
souhaité y aller à klose et les vagues
hausse et puis tout récemment depuis
cette année il ya deux autres qui
viennent d'entrer sur le marché un
groupe australien et un groupe des pays
bas jan louwers de l'australie et l'esat
hodara des pays-bas d'envoyer à la
concurrence merci frédéric pourcel